weißt du dass wir neue nachbarn
weißt du dass wir neue nachbarn haben
ja das weiß ich
ich habe sie bereits kennen gelernt
ich habe
bereits kennengelernt
hast du sie auch schon kennengelernt
nein ich kenne sie noch
nein ich kenne sie
nicht
sind sie nett
ich denke dass sie sympathisch sind
wir müssen sie aber zuerst etwas näher
kennen lernen
weißt du denn
ihre namen weißt du denn schon ihre
namen
ja ich weiß wie sie heißen
wir laden sie zum essen ein so lernt ihr
euch kennen
wir laden sie zum essen ein
so lernt ihr euch kennen
gute idee dann weiß ich auch wer unsere
nachbarn sind gute idee dann weiß ich
auch wer unsere nachbarn sind
hallo kurz und manfred
hallo kurt und manfred
ich möchte euch meinen mann vorstellen
ihr kennt euch ja noch nicht
hallo zusammen ich heiße ideen
hallo zusammen ich heiße eugen
es freut mich
lernen
guten tag beugen
guten tag
deine frau bernadette haben wir ja schon
kennengelernt
deine frau berner
haben wir ja schon kennengelernt
ich heiße manfred und das ist kurz
wollt ihr etwas trinken
wir haben gerade gekocht und unser essen
steht bereit
statt dass wir bei euch etwas trinken
können will ja bei uns etwas essen
können wir ja bei uns etwas essen
ja gerne wir möchten nämlich gern wissen
wie ihr wohnt
hat euch das essen geschmeckt
es war köstlich
ich habe eine frau
ich habe eine frage
kennt ihr ein gutes fitnesscenter in der
nähe
ich weiß dass es am zentralplatz ein
gutes fitnesscenter hat
ich kenne es aber nicht aus erfahrung
ich war nie da
ich kenne eine frau die dort trainiert
ich kenne eine frau
wird
deshalb weiß ich dass es ein gutes fit
center ist
deshalb weiß ich dass es ein gutes
fitnesscenter ist
ich weiß aber leider nicht wie es
ist
ich weiß
leider nicht wie es heißt
er trainiert gern
ich weiß damit nichts an
an ihn
ich weiß damit nichts anzufangen
du weißt halt auch nicht wie es ist den
ganzen tag zu sitzen
das stimmt
ich kenne nur meine arbeit auf der
baustelle
seid ihr neu in der stadt
seit der 9
statt
kennt ihr die stadt noch nicht gut
kennt ihr die stadt
nicht gut
ja wir wissen erst wo unsere firmen sind
und heute war ich im supermarkt
jetzt weiß ich wo der supermarkt ist
wenn ihr etwas wissen möchte
könnte
fragen
[Musik]
wenn ihr es
möchtet könnt ihr uns fragen
wisst ihr schon wer sonst noch im haus
wohnt
wir haben die ältere frau von unten
einmal im flur gesehen
jetzt wissen wir dass sie war
da heisst
jetzt wissen wir dass sie wagner heißt
sonst kennen wir noch niemanden im blog
kennen sich hier alle mit namen
wir wissen auch nicht alle namen
aber einige kennen wir halt vom sehen
einige kennen wir halt vom sehen
als wir hierher gekommen sind konnten
wir aber schon julia
das ist eine schulfreundin von mir die
noch immer über uns wohnt
wir lernten schnell alle kennen
aber wir lernten
schnell alle kennen
aber
den jahren weiß ich noch immer nicht
alle namen
aber
nach vielen jahren weiß ich noch immer
nicht alle namen
die leute im haus ziehen ja auch oft ein
und aus
so kann man nicht immer alle beim namen
kennen
jetzt wissen wir es
jetzt wissen
s
und wenn wir nicht mehr weiterwissen
fragen wir euch
es ist schon spät
ich denke wir sollten jetzt nach hause
gehen
wir müssen
in unsere wohnung fertig einrichten
morgen unsere wohnung fertig einrichten
wir wissen sonst nicht wann wir zeit
dafür finden
und nochmals vielen dank für die
einladung
das verstehen wir
lasst es uns wissen wenn ihr mal hilfe
braucht oder nicht mehr weiter wisst
wir sind froh euch jetzt zu kennen
[Musik]